so there's this story called Avengers
versus the X-Men where name of the
Submariner goes crazy with the Phoenix
force and kills most everybody in
wakanda so then like the incursion start
the Multiverse is coming to an end black
panther reforms the Illuminati he brings
Neymar on board and he's like when all
this is over I'm gonna kill you right
for what you did to wakanda so there
comes this point when Thanos invades
earth right like what's left of wakanda
gets destroyed and then sure he gives
black panther this knife this ceremonial
dagger and says put it where it belongs
so there comes a point when the
Illuminati have to destroy an alternate
world to save their own and so when
Neymar's on this world getting ready to
detonate this antimatter bomb and
destroy it black panther teleports down
stabs anymore in the chest kicks him off
the platform leaves him for dead on the
world and then his name or starts to
wake up he realizes what's happening and
black panther detonates the anti-matter
bomb and blows up the world with Neymar
on it it was a ridiculously amazing
moment make sure you guys follow for
more content